buenos días hoy es la mañana antes de la
comida del día de gracias y me siento un
poco enfermo de la panza así que he
decidido trabajar arduamente en los
vídeos del st para olvidar mi malestar
estamos ahora en el examen número 3 en
el examen 3 de la guía de estudio
oficial del s atem en la página 518 ya
acabamos el examen 1
el examen 2 así que vamos a la primera
sección de este tercer examen ya hemos
avanzado bastante y empecemos con el
primer problema que dice algo así
estamos en el problema número uno y dice
3x + 9 esto es igual a 5 x + 15 x + 1 y
me preguntan cuánto vale x esto ya
empieza a parecer un poco más
interesante al menos empezamos con una
ecuación así que para esto déjenme
restar primero 3 x de ambos lados de la
ecuación
aquí voy a restar 3x y de este lado
también voy a restar 3x pero además voy
a restar menos 1 de ambos lados de la
ecuación de este lado voy a restar menos
1 y de este lado también voy a restar
menos 1 de tal manera que que me va a
quedar esto del lado izquierdo
esto del lado derecho del lado izquierdo
estos dos se van y me quedan 9 menos 19
- 1 es 8 mientras que del lado derecho
me queda 5 x menos 3 x esto es lo mismo
que 2x y después 11 estos dos se van
georges y he vivido a ambas partes de
esta ecuación entre 2 entre 2 y entre 2
voy a obtener que este y éste se van
jones y el valor de x que estoy buscando
es igual a 8 entre 2 lo cual me da 4
perfecto x vale 4 y ya está mi primera
respuesta de este examen número 3 por
fin aquí tengo una primera respuesta y
vamos a resolver entonces el problema
número 2 que yo creo que me cabe por
aquí el problema número
2 me dice si tengo la secuencia 7,15 com
a 31,63 coma y así sigue y sigue y sigue
dice el primer término de esta secuencia
de 7 bueno
aquí está y cada término posterior está
determinado por multiplicar el término
anterior por m y sumarle n es decir que
esté para llegar a este otro lo vamos a
multiplicar por un número m y después le
vamos a sumar un número n de tal manera
que llegamos al 15 el 15 para llegar al
lo vamos a multiplicar por un número m y
después le sumamos un número n y
llegamos al 31 y lo que me preguntan es
cuánto vale m
cuánto vale n y bueno hay dos formas de
resolverlo
la primera es pensar un poco en esta
sucesión y ver qué es lo que estamos
haciendo del 7 para llegar al 15 bueno
creo que lo primero que nos damos cuenta
y creo que lo más lógico es que él
7 para llegar a 15 lo podemos ver como 7
por 2 7 por 2 + 1 7 por 2 es 14 14 + 1
es 15 entonces esta es una de las formas
en las cuales podemos escribir el 15
multiplicando el 7 por algo y sumándole
algo a ver y si pensamos del 15 al 31
bueno del 15 al 31
es lo mismo que multiplicado por 2 15
por 12 31 es exactamente lo mismo vamos
bien 15 por 2 más 1 15 por dos es 30 más
130 y 131 por lo tanto esta es otra
forma de ver el 31 como multiplicando el
15 por 2 y sumándole 1 y del 31 63
aunque lo que también funciona lo mismo
fíjate bien 31 lo podemos multiplicar
por 2 ya esto le sumamos 1 y esto me dan
31 por 2 es lo mismo que 62 más 1 63 63
que es justo el número al que queremos
llegar
entonces si nosotros nos damos cuenta de
ese patrón estamos observando que hay
que multiplicar al número anterior por 2
y a éste sumarle uno lo que quiere decir
que en este caso m vale 2 y n vale 1 en
esta asociación m vale 2 n vale 1 y con
esto obtenemos todos estos resultados
así que ya está si lo que me preguntan
es el valor de m
bueno pues podemos decir que me vale 2
ahora me si por alguna razón no
encuentras de una manera simple y
sencilla cómo llegar de un número a otro
puedes plantear un sistema de ecuaciones
es decir puedes decir que 7 lo vas a
multiplicar por un número llamado m te
vas a multiplicar por m y después le vas
a sumar otro cierto número llamado n y
esto te tiene que dar el siguiente
número el número 15 esto para la primera
ecuación y por otra ecuación podrías
pensar que 15 si lo multiplicamos por
ese mismo número m y le sumamos este
mismo número n me tienen que dar el
siguiente número de esta secuencia qué
es
y aquí ya obtendrías un sistema de
ecuaciones si esta ecuación de arriba la
multiplicó por menos 1
esto me quedaría menos este me quedaría
menos en lugar de más y éste me quedaría
menos y ahora si sumo estas dos
ecuaciones que me va a quedar 15 m menos
7 m
es lo mismo que 8 m 8 m este y éste se
van y solamente me quedaría 31 menos 15
lo cual es 16 y ahora dividiendo a ambos
lados entre 8 me queda que m es igual a
2 que es justo lo que tenía muy bien
aquí ya hay dos formas de resolver este
ningún problema así que vamos a resolver
el problema número 3 déjame borrar esto
de aquí y ok
tengo una tabla una pequeña tabla así
que vamos a ponerle aquí
esta va a ser parte de mi tabla eso
también va a ser parte de mi tabla
estamos en el problema número uno espera
espera espera
estamos en el problema número tres y me
dice lo siguiente que aquí tengo color
color y tengo tres posibles colores
tengo el color rojo
tengo el color blanco
color blanco
y tengo por otra parte el color azul
azul
ok por otra parte tengo medidas de la
talla y la talla
puede ser chica
chica puede ser mediana
diana
puede ser también grande grande y puede
ser extra grande extra grande muy bien
tengo cuatro tallas tres colores y me
dice el siguiente problema la tabla
siguiente muestra los diferentes colores
y las diferentes tallas de las playeras
que hay disponibles en la preparatoria
independencia cuantas combinaciones
diferentes de color y tamaño son
posibles cuantas combinaciones
diferentes de color y tamaños son
posibles
bueno pues realmente este problema está
muy sencillo no tienen ningún truco ni
ninguna magia de por medio tengo de
color rojo cuatro posibles tallas chica
mediana grande austral grande de color
blanco tengo cuatro posibles tallas
chica mediana grande o extra grande y de
color azul también tengo cuatro posibles
tallas chica mediana grande o extra
grande es decir que esencialmente la
respuesta a este problema es multiplicar
cuatro por tres cuatro tallas por tres
colores y esto es igual a dos
tengo 12 posibles combinaciones de color
y tamaño en esta preparatoria
independencia claro hablando de las
playeras entonces vamos a ver si me cabe
por aquí el problema número 4 a déjame
mejor borrar el pizarrón y vamos a poner
el problema número 4 el problema número
4 para que tenga bastante espacio
bueno ya con más espacio ahora sí te
puedo decir que es el problema número
cuatro porque nos pregunta lo siguiente
para cuáles de las siguientes funciones
efe de menos tres
esto es más grande que f de tres
existirá alguna de las opciones que nos
dan pues vamos a ver qué me dice el
inciso a el inciso am me dice que fx
esto es igual a 4 x cuadrado vamos a ver
si funciona en esta de hecho a simple
vista se nota que esto no va a funcionar
porque cuando elevamos al cuadrado menos
3 al cuadrado es exactamente lo mismo
que 3 al cuadrado es decir que efe - 3
quienes efe - 3 es lo mismo que 4 x
menos 3 elevado al cuadrado que por
cierto es lo mismo que 4
3 elevado cuadrado estos 9 que por
cierto esto es lo mismo que efe de 3
porque f de 3 es 4 por 3 elevado al
cuadrado que es 9 entonces esto no
funciona porque son exactamente iguales
efe de 3 y f de menos 3 es exactamente
lo mismo por lo tanto esta no es mi
respuesta vamos a ver el inciso b el
inciso pm dice
fx esto es igual a 4
aquí está peor porque ya no tengo ni
siquiera x por lo tanto para todas x f x
vale 4 es decir que f de menos 3 vale 4
y f 3 vale 4 es decir que son iguales
otra vez por lo tanto en este caso
tampoco funciona cuando fx es igual a 4
vale 4 para todas x y por lo tanto va a
valer 4 para menos 3 y para 3 entonces
esta no me funciona vamos a ver el
inciso abc el cis osce el inciso se me
dice lo siguiente
fx es lo mismo que 4 / x
esto podría funcionar vamos a ver si
funciona cuánto valdría efe de menos
tres
bueno pues efe - 3 es lo mismo que 4
entre menos 3 o sea menos 4
- cuatro derechos aquí está el menos y
cuánto vale efe de tres y creo que no me
va a funcionar
efe de tres es lo mismo que cuatro sobre
tres positivo y si te das cuenta aquí
este es mucho más grande que éste porque
éste es negativo y éste es positivo aquí
pasa lo contrario
efe 3 es más grande que efe de menos 3
por lo tanto que el inciso ser tampoco
es mi respuesta vamos a ver si el inciso
d es el que funciona el inciso de me
dice
fd x esto es igual a 4 - x kubica
creo que esta sí es la solución vamos a
ver quién es
efe de -3 bueno pues esto es lo mismo
que 4 - menos tres al cubo y cuantos
menos tres al cubo déjame ponerlo
primero de menos tres elevado al cubo y
esto es igual a 4 - 3 por 3 9 por 3 27
por menos 27 menos 27 porque me quedaría
menos por menos más x menos menos y 4 -
menos 27 esto es lo mismo que cuatro más
27 lo cuales 31 perfecto entonces aquí
es 31 muy bien y cuánto vale
efe de 3 pues efe de tres es 4 - 3
elevado al cubo pero 3 elevado al cubo
es lo mismo que 27 27 entonces me
quedaría 4 menos 27 lo cual es igual a
menos 23
lo cual es un número negativo y ya está
fíjate lo que pasó
efe de menos 3 esto es exactamente lo
mismo que 31 y por otra parte ft 3 esto
es lo mismo que menos 23 aquí esto es
negativo éste es positivo esto es mucho
más grande que éste por lo tanto efe - 3
es más grande que f de 3 en esta función
fx igual a 4 - x kubica por lo tanto
esta es mi respuesta correcta ya
encontré uno de los incisos y supongo
que si mi respuesta es única entonces
este es el ejercicio correcto el inciso
de muy bien vamos a ver el siguiente
problema todavía me da tiempo y vamos a
hablar del problema número 5 venga vamos
a darle al problema número 5 y me dice
lo siguiente la fuerza requerida para
estirar un resorte más allá de su
longitud natural es proporcional a que
tanto queremos estirar el resorte y si
alguna vez has visto algo de física o
mis vídeos de física según
viste esto la fuerza requerida vamos a
ponerlo aquí la fuerza que necesitamos
es igual a una constante cam a una
constante cam justo esta es la constante
de proporcionalidad es decir que tanto
se deja estirar el resorte por la voy a
multiplicar por la longitud que vamos
tirar porque tanto se va a estirar es
decir por equis con una fuerza de 15
libras
dejamos de una tabla si yo aquí tengo la
fuerza de que tengo a x y entonces
hacemos una pequeña tabla por aquí está
por acá este por acá y yo sé que con una
fuerza de 15 libras estiro el resorte 8
centímetros
streeter resulten ocho centímetros
entonces cuánta fuerza se necesitan para
estirar el resorte 20 centímetros lo que
me preguntan es cuánta fuerza necesito
para estirar el resultado 20 centímetros
y bueno podemos despejar de aquí a camps
y entonces obtener la fuerza es decir
que cuando yo tengo 15
fuerza esto es igual a la constante cam
que es justo lo que no sé por 8 x org y
sitech y despejó a cam y / 8 entre ambos
lados de la ecuación me va a quedar que
camps es exactamente lo mismo que 15
entre 8 y esto no se puede dividir ok si
k es igual a 15 entre 8 entonces cuando
x vale 20
cuánto vale f es decir f va a ser igual
a cam acá sabemos que vale 15 entre 8
por x pero x vale 20 en esta ocasión por
20 y cuántos esto pues esto es lo mismo
que aquí puedo sacar mitad me queda
cuatro aquí está con mitad me queda 10
-equipo sacar mitad me queda 5 aquí saco
mitad me queda 2 y entonces es 5 por 15
lo cual es 75 entre 2 y 75 entre 2 es
exactamente lo mismo que 37.5 libras es
la cantidad de fuerza que necesitamos
para estirar este resorte 20 centímetros
por total
la respuesta es 37.5 que es el inciso y
ya está de hecho también podríamos
resolver este problema como una regla de
tres es decir nos falta este dato 20 por
15 entre 8 y me va a dar del resultado
37 puntos 5 libras ya está el resultado
así que nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo